goodmorning believes nation today we're
going to talk about how you can study
efficiently rule number three is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always guys as you're listening if you
hear something that really really
resonates with you please leave it in
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired and
also as you write things down you're
much more likely to keep it in here as
well
enjoy
[Music]
and you may have heard of the Pomodoro
Technique everyone talks about it but in
case you haven't it's simply a technique
where you set a timer for about 25
minutes classically and then you work
only on one task during that 25-minute
session and I think a lot of people do
this and it's very useful but there are
some areas for improvement that I don't
think a lot of people take advantage of
so let me just wrap it fire give them to
you so number one and I've talked about
how much I'm a fan of the beeminder app
the beeminder blog is also a good
resource for productivity techniques and
experiments and one of the things that
they talk about is this thing they do
called talks well a talk is essentially
a Pomodoro session except for they use
about 45 minutes and then take 15 minute
breaks instead of the classic 25-minute
5 minute break structure so the tip here
is to experiment with the time intervals
don't just set yourself to 25 minutes
and assume that that's the only
potential interval that you could study
at find what works for you and the other
one is to put a piece of paper next to
you during your Pomodoro session and
whenever anything comes up it distracts
you maybe a phone call or the urge to
check Facebook or something
write it down now this lets you do two
things one you can remember where the
distraction was and if it happened to be
something urgent you can take care of it
during your break time but two as you
continue to do lots of Pomodoro sessions
over months and months you start to see
what are the common problem points what
comes up a lot that distracts you and
then you can take steps to prevent these
things so maybe if it's your phone you
forget to put it in do not disturb mode
well you can do that now if it's a
certain website do you really want to
visit because it's just so distracting
and draws you in then you can use an
extension like stay focused on Chrome to
block it during your study sessions very
useful stuff you have to schedule your
time don't just stuff studying in to
cracks in your schedule your schedule
should be built around studying what
does this mean this means have an exact
set time during the day when you start
to study for me I remember it was about
6:00 p.m. I would always say to myself
okay 6:00 p.m. I get back from school I
rest a little bit at 6:00 p.m. that's my
study time it starts how long does it go
well that depends on how much
assignments and homework I have but it
would go for at least an hour or two and
sometimes would go for four or five or
six hours and would start at 6:00 and
usually end like around 9:00 or 10:00 or
or after that any would vary but I think
what's really important to have that
starting time 6:00 no matter what six
sit down and study open the book sit
down study it doesn't have to be 6:00
for you just come up with your own time
and you're doing this every single day
what's important about this is that it
leads us to the next point which is you
have to get comfortable you have to slow
yourself down in order to study
effectively you can't rush the studying
process and one of the secrets that I
use is simply brute force right a lot of
the issues at the student that I dealt
with the things that I couldn't
understand I just forced them through
repetition and this repetition can take
time also you know you have to be
patient with yourself sometimes you're
not gonna understand the problem right
off the bat so you just kind of repeat
it repeat it Mull it over and mole it
over and that means sometimes it takes
you longer so instead of finishing a
quick little math assignment in an hour
it might take you three hours but that's
worth it if you calm yourself down get
comfortable
slow yourself down kind of open yourself
to absorbing this information all right
this is where the love it comes in if
you don't love it and what you're doing
is you're just kind of rushed studying
through stuff just to learn it like
cramming for an exam that's just
horrible that's horrible because all
you're trying to do is you're jumping
you're like a dog jumping through hoops
that's basically what you are when
you're doing that because you're saying
yourself well I got a pass to the exam
or to get into college to get good
grades so my parents like me that's just
coops like a dog you're jumping through
don't do that instead what you think
about is like this okay this subject
matter is really fast anyone you study
more let me learn why we're not know how
math interconnects with with history and
I want to know how to history and it
connects with science and I want to know
how this and this connected and I want
to know more depth about this thing here
that's how you got to think my general
process is you can think of it as diff
cell dfff okay
and the first step is deconstruction and
that entails taking learn X which is
generally very large nebulous learn
- and breaking it down into component
parts and making it a measurable goal as
opposed to just learn because that
doesn't have an endpoint and what that
means with no end point that you can't
celebrate passing certain milestones so
first it's kind of deciding on exactly
what you're trying to accomplish and
then asking a set of questions either to
Google and or to experts such as who's
good at this who shouldn't be that's a
very important one so if I'm looking at
say ultra endurance running I would say
who's good at this who shouldn't be
meaning the people who are already built
like spiders they're genetically
predisposed to be very good at this so
they might be succeeding despite bad
training habits I want to find the
person who has bad attributes like
somebody who's 240 pounds yeah alia the
soccer but it's like you get to find
somebody who's and I did somebody is
like 230 240 pounds really big maybe a
little chunky and they still run fifty
hundred mile races that means most
likely that they are compensating for
bad attributes with good training I
would say who are the best coaches it's
where the most controversial coaches
controversy mm-hmm and look at the
training methodologies the coaches and
the most important thing there is not
was the coach formerly extremely
successful in their children's sport was
helpful were they able to replicate the
results and I've lost track are we in
the D still are still in D okay D we're
deconstructing so deconstructing but
that's that's I would say the most
important information gathering phase
the next is selection and that's doing
80/20 analysis so looking at the many
different ways you could train for your
goal which you've already defined or
practice for it say with Spanish like
one-on-one lessons versus textbook
versus this versus that which is the
other thing versus vocabulary
memorization what are the 20% that are
going to get me 80% to my goal right
what are the what are the critical few
and then focusing on this so you would
you would you would do this selection
process and very often let's say
language it's the highest frequency
words you don't have to learn up 1000
words top out in 1000 words I'm going to
get you through 75% 80% of any
conversation
then you have sequencing putting things
in the right order this is I think the
most neglected secret sauce it's like
how do you take what you've decided what
you've gathered and put it into a
logical progression this is where things
often fail and I'm really this first and
like like for each skill asking yourself
like what are the prerequisites to the
skill or I'm doing that right now
gymnastics like for a press handstand or
for a like a planche a little easier to
describe so planche is I could push up
on the ground you lean forward so your
shoulders are way out here and you lift
your feet off the ground okay so what
are the prerequisites to a planche for
people who can't do it what are the
prereqs and if someone says well like
today we're going to practice this well
what should I be able to do before this
technically and physically maybe even
emotionally right if you're trying to
learn how to be an EMT or something like
that okay that's how you piece together
this sequence I spent a lot of time on
the sequencing but this is the exact
order that I fall and the last one which
is almost universally neglected their
death the third F is steaks not stakes
like on a grill but steaks like through
a vampire chest but at meeting
consequences you need to build in
incentives because for most of us who
are trying to learn something not always
sure these are extracurriculars right
sick if you're trying to learn something
for your job the incentive is don't get
fired or get a raise right you have
built-in incentives but for I'm going to
learn fill in the blank right I'm going
to learn how to play tennis in my spare
time or try to learn a little bit of
French before I go to France like six
months from now
those are extracurriculars and they will
get crowded out of your life if you
don't build in incentives meaning
rewards or punishments so you can
certainly read all about this and 4-hour
chef but the basic idea of you one
example would be a betting pool that
could be with like a friend where if you
miss a workout you have to pay your
friend is certain that money could be a
dollar could be five dollars could be I
know someone who works at Google makes a
lot of money who had an agreement with
his training partner they had to pay
each other a dollar if they missed a
workout and that was the first time he
stuck with his workout lost a hundred
pounds
Wow so uh so so the amount can have a
disproportionate impact but I also know
people for instance who get together
four or five friends and have a
competition like who loses the most body
fat by x-point time eight weeks without
great you want to learn that you want to
learn how to exercise properly with the
goal of losing fat put some money on the
line you will work infinitely harder to
not lose andra dollars then you will to
make a hundred dollars so the stakes I
think is the consequences are very
important you can find say
accountability coaches through places
like stick comm stic KK comm coach dot
me which I'm actually have some
involvement with and others but you need
incentives you're only going to be as
faithful to your goals as your
incentives compel you to be that's it
sweet
so let's quick recap deconstruction
deconstruct first s selection 80/20
80/20 but then then the the second s is
is sequencing you having things in the
right order and the last s is stakes
stakes there you go this it diff step
number four to clear your mind of all
distractions I used to hold the record
for the fastest to memorize a deck of
cards the United States and sometimes
before I would memorize the deck of
cards my brain would be worried about
things in my life or things that were
going on so what I would do to clear my
mind of all distractions is I would
close my eyes and I would visualize
those scenarios the way that I wish they
were or the way that I hope they would
be one day and then I went over my I'll
be relieved of that stress and then I
would memorize a deck of cards clear
your mind of all distractions maybe
close your eyes and visualize the things
the way you wish they could be and then
focus on your study a lot of people just
jump in this and learn fast I want to
learn speed right now what I learned you
know the new language I want to learn
all these new skills I want to learn all
these things and what is happening is
people are very transient with their
learning goals what anything like that
I mean they're kind of phony but they
really don't want to learn it I'd like
to learn this I like a limit someday I'd
like to learn this someday I'd like to
learn French
someday I'd like to learn how to do
photos some days I like to blog some day
I like to do video and they never
actually learn it because learning
doesn't happen some day it has to happen
consistently and that's the thing if
we're really going to get the point
where you learn something faster we have
to approach learning itself differently
it can't be these one-off little goals
of little things we want to learn that
doesn't work for people they don't stay
consistent just like people don't stay
consistent on a diet if just their goal
is lose five pounds there has to be a
broader vision for who they are and what
they want to be about and what they want
their life to be about if they're going
to stay on a diet
same thing for learning if you're going
to stay on a learning habit then you
have to have a bigger vision for
yourself so let's start with this
conversation if you want to learn
something faster you must first and
foremost know the connection between
what you want to learn and your dream
life your real lifestyle that you want
to have I tell you all the time like
don't just come up with things you want
to learn because that's what we want to
learn everything by human build we are
curious animals
we're definitely curious I mean we are
literally the curiosity killed the cat
sort of society right now everyone wants
to learn 50 new things immediately but
no one ever learns anything why because
it's not real for them it's a transient
desire if you want to become a great
learner it has to be attached to a dream
life of yours it's true a true life
style that you see for yourself
let me example a lot of people say I'd
like to learn some French that someday
I'm going to learn French someday I'll
learn how to talk to French because it's
a romantic language I like the food and
they give lots of ounces on cheese and
wine I like that right I'm French so I
can say a little bit of that okay so I
have a little piece of freshening I
should say so here's what's happening if
I don't have the vision for myself
someday going to experience France or
someday going to place where they speak
French or someday having real
interactions with a human being
speaking French and it's important to me
and it's a deep sort of dream desire
vision for the
I'm never going to do the work to
actually learn French there's no y there
you have to know what you want of your
life before you become a master learner
let me say that again
you have to know what you want of your
life before you become a master learner
until I know what I want my life to be
about
what I want to experience on daily basis
what do I want my dreams to be who I
want to be I don't know what to learn
I'm just going to be curious about
things and I'll dabble in them but that
path the real true mastery is that part
where we say okay what I want my life to
be about now let me develop the
knowledge the skills the competencies
the capabilities to build into that life
and that's where you get someone becomes
a master learner now I'm not saying you
have to know your ultimate purpose in
life
before you can learn anything I'm just
saying if you want to learn faster start
figuring out that purpose start thinking
about your direction you'll learn a lot
faster my favorite study hacking
university was to listen to music not
just any music specifically it was the
Phantom of the Opera instrumental
soundtrack and a Jurassic Park
instrumental soundtrack and I listened
to those over and over and over and over
again and I didn't know why I just felt
like it helped me be more receptive to
the information I felt that I absorbed
it more and I could study better and I
just looped those tracks over and over
and over and over and over again now
science has shown us that listening to
instrumental music especially Mozart if
you can handle Mozart music that really
can get you in the zone and really open
your mind up and be receptive to
information coming in we've gone so far
as to even make playlists for studying
that you can check out in our 85 series
and so music I feel is really important
I think music sets the tone for a lot of
things whatever you're trying to do in
life if you want to be motivated you can
listen to inspiring soundtracks if you
want to focus you can listen to
instrumental classical music we're
studying especially I found that that
really really really helped and so it
encourage you to make a playlist that is
focus on instrumentals you could try the
ones that we put together or you can
create your own just make sure that
they're instrumental there's no lyrics
because the lyrics can distract you and
that you're playing the same songs
repeatedly over and over and over and
over again so you don't get too
distracted and go somewhere so that was
my biggest study hack that really helped
me to university and I hope it helps you
too
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because you cheated argh
our ask me too so there's a topic you'd
like me to cover in the next addition to
believe life leave it down the count's
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from this video what was your favorite
takeaway how are you now going to study
more efficiently what did you learn or
do you have a tip to share as well
please leave it down in the comments
below I'm excited to find out what you
guys have to say finally I want to give
a quick shout out to will suka thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word it really really really
means a lot to me and I hope you're
enjoying the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is
much love have an amazing day and I'll
see you soon
[Music]
nobody's born smart we all start at zero
can't talk can't walk certainly can't do
algebra adding reading riding riding a
bike nobody's good at anything
first there was a time when I couldn't
count to ten and Shakespeare had learned
ABCs just like the rest of us
thankfully born to learn slowly surely
you stumble flip crawl fall and fail
control frustrating confusing triangle
struggling until one day walk one foot
in for the other one idea on top the
next each wrong answers making your
brain a little bit stronger
failing is just another word for oh and
you keep going
dinner is learning and knowing that
you'll get it even cat and garden
yes because the experiencing
competitiveness in the whole universe
are built on basic idea that anybody
anywhere can understand
whoever you are we're at your bar you
only have to know one
you can learn anything
[Music]